some of you may know that i
spoke about gdd at ndc oslo about seven
years ago and it caused a little bit of
a
[Music]
you know amount of attention and i
already wanted to kind of return to it
my seven years later now um and try and
put a little bit more structure around
some of the guidance um that i would
give you during tdg today so
whereas that prior talk was an exciting
rant um
this talk is probably slightly more uh
structured in in how we're looking
basically
today okay
most of you know this it's kind of dull
it means i'm old i've got a lot of
slides to get through let's kind of move
over
who mr keeper is um i work on an open
source
project for c-sharp and python called
writer we love to have contributors
um we do the same thing as mediator does
but we also do basically
over middleware a messaging video where
like rap and queue and kafka if you need
to
all right so we're going to talk about
um the bulk of this
session will be about fallacies and
a principle that you should use instead
for tdd and i see still permeating the
industry
and then i will talk a little bit about
clean architecture a very short section
because it's useful i think to
understand how it can fit into helping
our tdt practice in a little summer at
the end
all right so what do i think some of the
key
fallacies are that we we still propagate
in the industry
this to me is the biggest one
um this idea that we have that
developers write unit tests
nothing could be further from the truth
if we're doing tdd
so if we look at how uh wikipedia
defines
uh unit testing it says to isolate
issues that may arise
uh substitutes such as method starts
mock objects fakes and test harnesses
can be used to assist testing a module
in isolation what's all that
well the isolation piece is key to what
people are trying to do
with the testing the original it comes
from very classical
testing and you yourself are divided
into modules you treat each module like
a black box
and you say i will test this black box
in isolation of all the other black
boxes
and i will therefore know that any
failures relate to something that's
happened inside my black box
and to do that what i have to do is make
sure that the black box doesn't
anything that it talked to outside the
box any connections had to other modules
i replaced those with some kind of
substitute right
and so generally where this practice has
been taken into the world of test driven
development we've said
the unit is essentially my class and
therefore anything my class talks to you
i have to mock out my class is
essentially my old school module
and i'm using this unit testing practice
to basically do that
and at its height what this led to was
this
idea that became known as need driven
development
um particularly strongly advocated
uh often by what's called the london
school
as opposed to the chicago school which
is more we'll talk about later
and say for example uh steve friedman
now prices are growing object charter
software
tests and knee driven development is
this idea of outside
in where essentially you say i start at
the outside i move in as i find
things that i may later need to build i
kind of mock them out
and then i go away and i build one of
those things that i've knocked out and i
mock out
and as i build it i mock out things it
needs and i start basically
until i get down to everything basically
that has been mocked now has a concrete
replacement
so it it requires a couple of things
that we have to do
the first is we either have to work in
this very top-down fashion where we
start with a test at the outer layer
and we say right in order to fill in the
details i'm going to need a thing
i can't have a concrete thing because
this thing basically only had to talk to
itself
therefore i need to mock out those
things right so you write a test
and as you go to implement stuff you say
wanting to mock out that operation i'll
put a mock in my test i need to mock on
that operation i'll put a mock in my
testing to knock out that operation put
mark in my test
i tested up to all these marks now which
basically are
defining the contract of what i will be
calling
and and effectively my test is
generating those marks
there's a bit of a problem there in the
i don't
like my test gets written as i'm writing
the implementation
the classical tdd model says hey red
write a fading test
then green go to implement it then red
go to refactor but i'm i'm i'm tying red
and green together horribly here and my
refractory step often doesn't happen
because i've spent so much time thinking
about the implementation
so really i'm just directly writing the
code and the test is being written at
the same point and
i might as well be testing after the
other model you can do this with is
literally you get crc cards and
i can do upfront design okay and say oh
i'm going to go and
create the design of all my objects and
then i know what i'm going to call
so i can then put the mock statements in
when i write my test
because i know that it's going to call
all those other classes
and then effectively i can write my test
uh now ahead of my class as i go to my
implementation i'll make those calls to
the mocks i've defined early
but you've still done upfront design
your entire class hierarchy
you fleshed out and your tdd is no
longer giving you
feedback as you go along uh on your code
so the consequence of this
approach is that we don't do tdd in the
sense
of tdd as a contract first approach
to writing our code the idea behind tdd
is that i develop the contract that my
code will present
to express a given behavior that is
needed by the system
this approach is about designing a class
hierarchy
and testing it afterwards and even if
you're pretty much
writing the cut the tests simultaneously
with the code you're not really doing
test first you are trapped in a pattern
of test after
where you're getting feedback on the
design that already exists
rather than your design being improved
in your effector instead
so i spoke about this as far back as
and we talked about this basically the
idea of a fragile test
something where effectively we're saying
hey these tests essentially are not
particularly robust because of the
mocking
and the issue becomes that as soon as
i have to inject a lot of stuff into my
code
right which may not necessarily be the
right design
so i end up with a model that says my
class takes
interfaces of everything it can't just
new up a collaborator in its constructor
and use it
it must be passed into it as a
dependency that dependency must be some
kind of abstraction so in a strongly
typed language it would be an
interface um in a uh
dynamic language basically you have to
use some kind of duct typing
to replace it and that's led us into
this world
of um i've got ioc containers now
because
every object that i have has
a depend has dependencies and those
dependencies have dependencies those
dependencies have dependencies the graph
gets complicated and big
we need an ioc container to realize it
and yet if we didn't have that
if we just said i'm going to new up one
of these i don't need to inject it
um we might be able to get away with
poor man's di at the composition route
with that and not actually use an iot
container at all
so a lot of this thing people complain
about which it says oh we've got this
crazy world
everything's the interface and
everything's at ioc
huge amount of that comes from this
testing strategy i wanted to be able to
replace the things that my classes
depend upon
as a result of testing if i didn't have
that in many cases i would never have
surfaced
those things outside i'd have surfaced
them if
i was doing basically something like
open close principle
where essentially i wanted to have
different strategies around which my
code varied and i wanted to pass them in
i might have surfaced them if i had a
layer boundary issue where i
should need to depend on something
that's above me but those are genuine
software design concerns
um i wouldn't have suffered i wouldn't
have those interfaces
injected into my code just because of a
testing icon
and the problem becomes with all of
those statements inside my
test which tell me exactly how this code
interoperates with its neighbors is that
if i want to change
any of my neighbors then i'm going to
break
all of those tests and my experience of
this was very
in the past was very much along these
lines i once worked
on a system where we built um
god help us our own orm uh and
for reasons um and one of the problems
the things we did
that we did there was basically market
very heavily because we were
you know at that stage of our
understanding of tdd um
and it would spit out basically relevant
basically calls the database we would
check what database calls you were gonna
make
and we would assert this thing works you
know perfectly but it was completely
unchangeable because as soon as you
tweaked one thing
over here in your code basically to
represent i want a new
parameter huge numbers of our tests
would work
and that and that behaviour system
problem where you change one thing
you get a sea of red and all your mops
started failing
you need to go through and literally
correct all your marks it's a huge
problem
because the promise of tdd is around
refractory
right we end up with what we call over
specified software
my test has become coupled to my
implementation details
my test understands how i intend to
implement that code
my test should not be coupled to my
implementation details
right i should not be thinking to myself
in order to basically change this
behavior i have to change these tests
the tests should assert a behavior
continuously
and if you change your behavior you
should only change the test
that basically exercises that behavior
not every test inside
all right so what's the kind of
equivalent principle
to this well the principle that we're
looking for much more
is that developers write what we call
developer tests
why is why is that different well
it's important to understand that kent
um
never effectively uh talked about unit
tests
in fact if you read his book tdd by
example
he only uses the sent that the word unit
test wants
and he uses that to say that he doesn't
actually use unit tests
that's the only reference in the book
what's happened is that in casual
conversation people would refer to unit
testing and tools like j
unit and x units actually an n unit kind
of effectively established this the word
units part of the terminology
and people looked at that and said oh
unit testing
there's tons of advice out there about
unit testing and i'll look if i've got
unit tests i need integration tests
or when i need acceptance tests people
bought
the whole farm of unit testing but that
was never
anything that was described originally
by tdd
it doesn't it's just not there right um
so
what what what should we actually be
writing right
well one of the key things that gives us
a bit of a clue
is refactoring right remember that the
cycle is
red green and refactor
and in red we write a failing test
we're essentially saying that there's
some behavior in the system
we want to basically prove that the code
under test
provides that and initially we'll write
something red so we know that our test
will genuinely fail because the
behavior's not there yet
we then go green using the cheapest
approach that we can to get green we
copy
and paste stuff out of stack overflow um
we ask questions on twitter and paste
lines of code from twitter if we need to
the goal is to find the algorithm and
not to write good code
right once we have an algorithm that
makes the code the test go
green we then do design we design the
refactoring step
and the purpose of refactoring is to
improve our implementation
but not change our behavior
and by the behavior what we mean
is the contract that your api that you
are developing expresses with the world
now i use the word api generically
the public methods on a class are an api
right i don't mean in a sense http or
rest or anything like that right
but your contract is what you
effectively are discovering by the
process of tdd
you care about that outside not about
the internals
so the key idea here is that once i've
got that contract established i
know what the behavior of this class
should be i can then go in my
refactoring step
and improve the design i can keep
changing it and provide that it stays
green
i know that the changes i'm making are
safe i'm still preserving the behavior
that i wanted
make a little change the behavior test
is still great make a little
implementation still green like i don't
change the implementation check it's
still green
make a little change to implementation
just check it check it's still green and
i can keep building out this
implementation
right one of the things that people
often miss is
if i essentially is part of their
refactoring process need to break out of
class
because i decide this thing's got too
many responsibilities i want to break
out class
that's going to be essentially private
to my module internal for example in c
sharp or underscoring i say python
effectively
i don't write tests for that it's
covered by the tests that cover the
behavior
right i already have code coverage for
it the code coverage comes from the test
that i'm currently writing
right that doesn't need a separate test
when our behavior is stable we don't
need to change
the tests okay so kent basically
um posted a basically a set of uh test
principles and
this is one of one of the key ideas
right if our contract
does not change if the api that we are
currently dealing with in other words
the public exports from a given module
don't change right then no
tests should need to change if what
we're doing is going in and changing
some of our implementation details
we should better change the
implementation of our classes and never
break any tests
and if our strategy around mocking
means that as soon as we change
implementation details or
test break because the marks effectively
now need changing
we're doing it wrong
so ken basically uh on twitter
quite recently said this right
tess should have kept the behavior of
the code and decoupled from the
structure of the code seeing tesla fell
in both accounts what he means by that
is by the behavior it means the contract
that the class is expressing right
that's what we coupled to
we don't couple essentially to the
implementation details
and one of the things you find when
mentally you switch this approach you
find a couple of very interesting things
first is essentially that you begin to
actually do a proper red dream
refactoring process
because you stop doing design up front
of your implementation details which is
which is a requirement of effectively a
unit testing approach it's why people
basically say
i'm going to test after because they
because because they can't see a
difference
because they don't they don't genuinely
experience a red green refactor
approach so you find that you're
refactoring more
you find that you're suspending design
decisions until the refactoring step
and you find that your tests now reach
that
laudable xp goal of being documentation
for your code
because you have clear examples of how
to use your contract
and often when i look at you know test
suites that i've seen out there
they're just a spray of mocks um you
know even if someone basically then
factors all those mocks out
or worse use some horrific auto mocking
kind of fixture
which is basically a bad wrong fun if
you've got it anymore
but use that kind of approach you can't
see very easily
what is the contract what is the example
how would i do this in my own code
you should better look at the test and
say oh that's how i use that feature
great hey i can cut and paste the code
out the test pretty much
put it in what i need and then just
alter it to my own purposes
that's what tests are for
and so ken basically said uh this
basically in a conversation that was
affected by martin um fowler effectively
between himself from dhh after dhh said
i'm giving up on
um tdd there was a kind of stupid
conversation and
a lot of the conversation came around to
this particular topic that
the problem was people had misunderstood
what tdd was they were practicing unit
testing
and had gone into this whole world of
mock all my dependencies
and ken said basically i don't go very
far down the mock path right
your test is completely coupled to the
implementation of the interface
of course you can't change anything
without breaking the tests
so tests shouldn't be looking to use
mocks to isolate the system under test
right tests are not unit tests
and the consequences basically of using
mocks to reserve indirect
outputs is that you couple your test to
your details
right so um the td community has done
this for quite a long time and been
quite
open about it it's just that people
don't really listen
so if you go to the c2 wiki and if you
really want to understand anything much
about
tdd xp it needs to come out of that era
the ct wiki is still
useful repository of knowledge but this
dates to the mid-noughties
um and it defined the following it said
any unit test
value implicates one and one only unit
the way that you get defect localization
is you say
i've got localization because it must be
in that black box which is isolated
in db write programmer tests sometimes
called developer tests
right and failure implicates the most
recent edit
your localization is to what you just
changed
if you work test by test right you do a
little bit of work
run the tests do a little bit of work
run the test
a little bit of work run the tests the
amount of code
that essentially cause red tests is
probably
four or five lines that you just changed
you have
absolutely got defect localization
because it's something you just added
and a lot of tdt advocates say if you
get unexpected red
what do you do you revert you revert
that change
and then you go and do it again and this
time you try and get it so that you
don't basically make rep
now actually i'm not as strict as that i
tend to say you know maybe sometimes
debugging that's helpful
because i don't really understand
immediately what went wrong and a little
bit of debugging might actually
help me understand oh oh yeah i see what
went wrong okay
maybe they're not reverting rewriter
maybe then i can just i can fix and
change it
right but tdd is about doing programmer
or developer testing
right we don't really use mocks
where failure implicates the most recent
edit um
and well it's a contract first approach
where we are designing the api for a
module
and it is that contract effectively and
it's expression that we want to see
in the tests not um isolation code
mock-up code etc
and of course once you get rid of unit
tests you also basically throw things
like integration tests in the trash bin
too
right that distinction doesn't really
exist it never has that on dvd
so this is basically the definition that
you need to basically kind of
get get internalized on the c2 wiki
testing development produces developer
tests fairly implicates the developer's
modulation edit
you don't need to use mock objects and
you avoid debug debugging as you can by
reverting that last edit
that's what test driven development is
right so td is a process of discovery
um and don't use marks right okay
um now having said that
right having pushed you in that
direction there are a couple of cases
where
a ken originally in tgd by example
describes using mods right so mocks and
all those things are actually part of
the original first book that came out
and uh one of the key things we need
from tdd is it's fast binary feedback it
must be fast
right and to do that we need to avoid
things that basically will slow us down
the other thing is we must
run all of our tests together so we need
to avoid
things that cause problems where the
shared state
whether where one test could impact
another test
so tests are isolated from each other we
need to run run them in parallel
and typically the problem becomes what
we call a shared fixture a database
a file something where multiple tests uh
talking to it could cause one test out
to influence the other
and that's a condition for using a mark
right
where essentially you want to replace a
piece of shared fixture and say i'm just
going to basically replace that with
some kind of in-memory dummy
that can effectively be very easily
recreated for an individual test
and you can do this stuff by doing
something like tearing you know creating
and tearing down a database with every
single test
but the problem with that basically is
it becomes slow
right and so what we need to do is make
sure that what we
is we keep speed as well as basically
isolation of tests from each other
and that means we quite commonly think
about using some kind of test double
uh to replace shared fixture components
that's typically io
we can also use marks where essentially
tests become fragile
because they're talking to say for
example across the network
to some third-party service which may or
may not be available
and we don't really want to have a
dependency on that for our test it's
slow
and effectively it's fragile right but
that's all we really want to use mocks
for that's all the
the whole reason marks are including
regional book is to solve problems with
shared fixture
solve problems of slow tests so a
problem with fragile tests
that's the reason to use mocks not
isolation dependencies
the second real problem we see out there
is this idea that the
trigger for a new test is a new function
we see people writing something saying
oh
yeah i need any method in my class i
better spin up and write a test for that
and even wikipedia has this line saying
what you do is you write a test that
defines a function oral
improvements to a function so this idea
is focusing on the function
as the key unit of abstraction that
we're dealing with right
and in particular we're seeing tdd is
this idea of preconditions and post
conditions
there we've got some things that are
true before a function is called and
things that are true after a function is
called
and the test simply asserts and it's set
up that given us preconditions we have
these post conditions
and typically in a kind of o world where
we're looking at some kind of object in
its state and we're saying
hey it had this state before i run this
method i have that it has the state
after
and that leads us to very much fun to
focus on
hey every function that i have on my
class
requires a test and i even see people
having conversations
saying oh how do you test the private
methods
on your class right um
so that becomes a bit of a problem right
um
because people start to believe that
this function is the system
under test i'm thinking all the time
about functions and how and how i test
and even there's a lot of ideas around
primaritized testing i'll worry about
how can i exercise the different
possible combinations
that my my function expresses right um
uh people start to talk about test
coverage and say do i
need to test this getter and setter
because you know do i
that's a that's a function of my classes
um should i test my getters and setters
and they get
lost in this whole conversation about
well maybe you don't really need a
hundred percent test coverage getting
started can't fail
um and it's really a pointless
discussion because this is not our goal
right and quite often when we look at
this model of mocks
and unit tests and functions being a
target
we end up in this world what we said we
have to have these acceptance tests
because what we've tested in our
tdd is these fine grains
of our application um but we need bigger
tests to test they all fit together
so we'll have to have integration tests
and we'll have to have acceptance tests
because
it turns out tdd isn't testing our
system it's testing these tiny little
atomic units of our system right
and again that's not true that's not
what we're trying to achieve
now the problem with these tests is
they're very much focused on
i'm going to provide you some parameters
basically
to the test and i'm going to produce an
output
i'm going to tell you very little about
why you might be calling that function
what is the behavior in the domain
that we are trying to basically encode
that we are
looking at i can't often see that i can
just see
hey i've got this method called do
something and it adds five to seven um
and it seems to come back with the
answer 26.
i don't understand why why would it do
that right
and nothing in the test tells me maybe
there's some mocks in there that help us
sir why
how it does that nothing the test tells
me right
and that's not the point there's this
whole notion essentially we had
of executable specifications that i
wouldn't need to do documentation
anymore because i could go and read the
tests
right people laugh at this idea and they
go
i gotta look at my test suite there's no
way i can leave that documentation
because
um uh you know look at the test you
couldn't possibly interpret the system
from the tests this whole idea is wrong
they never ask themselves
maybe it's my test that is wrong i think
my tests are just so badly written
that's why i can't do that
and so it's not the idea that's the
problem that's why people have been
writing tests
as the problem you write tests the wrong
way and you can't clearly see
what's going on right
so from the from the dawn of tdd right
this has been the this has been this has
been the actual statement that was made
the trigger for a new test is a new
behavior
the dawn of tdd that's been basically
what tdd's been about
right this is an example
in kent's book of what you are testing
we are testing that we need to be able
to add amounts in two different
currencies and convert the result given
a set of exchange rates
i'm not testing a function i'm not
testing
a particular class hierarchy that i've
developed the crc cards
i am testing a requirement that is a tdd
test
right right nowadays we tend to rewrite
these
as given a set of exchange rates when we
add amounts in two different currencies
then we convert the result but this is
exactly what tdd was talking about from
the very very beginning
right so if i rewrite that given a set
of exchange rates when i add two amounts
of different currencies together
then i get a result in the first
currency we get a classic
uh what we think of now basically as you
know given when then test right given
the state the world before the test
when i exercise the behavior under test
then we spread the following challenges
right gwt sometimes people think oh hey
we went away and we fixed cdd and we
presented this new thing given when then
right that's exactly how it's been since
the beginning right given when then it's
just another way of expressing that same
concept that's basically how you do tdd
um it's the same as a four-fold test
which is uh set up given exercise when i
verify it verify it then
tear down right so set up exercise
verifying tear down
which has been encoded into x unit tools
since the dawn of time
right and it's the same as that to
arrange an assert which has the same set
of principles
testing is about doing uh expressing a
behavior
and then writing tests the smallest
piece of code we can
to move from where we are towards
implementing that behavior
and that is is it is this that led dan
to make this statement
right so dan originally made the
statement very early on in tdd history
and his point was
um uh tested the behavior tdd's behavior
driving development was
if i that the word test to confuse
people it
started bringing in ideas like unit
testing acceptance testing and
integration testing
and the key to what we were doing was
actually behavior
right
so that's the key not
anything that came after bbd right
i don't want and i'm not particularly
advocating the bdd i think big d has
some of its basically own sets of issues
on particularly its outside-in model
and its current dependency on acceptance
testing right
but originally the observation of bdd
was
its behaviors that you are dealing with
in is the contracts
that you are dealing with in tdd
um so bdd originally when when dan
created this blog post it's just an
alternative name for tdd
so alternative way of naming it to
express that basically the key thing was
behaviours or contracts
not tests you could call it contract
driven
development that'd be an equally valid
name for what kent was basically
expressing
he just called it tdd because it
manifested itself in these executable
specifications i tested it written
and so although i mentioned bdd i'm not
advocating to be
as i say i think it has its own set of
problems i think it's lost its way from
what original ideals
so the rule in in tdd is that the the
next
test you write is the most obvious step
in implementing a use case or user story
right and in a sense that's the question
that answers everything
right the question of what test do i
write
next is the most obvious step towards
implementing a requirement i've got a
blank sheet of paper what do i write
i have a i should have a requirement
from a customer which says there's
something i need
in the domain right and the next
test i write is the most obvious thing i
can take in taking a small step towards
implementing that
maybe i have some acceptance criteria
from the customer about their
requirements maybe i can look at the
simplest of those acceptance criteria
and code that into a test right what's
the what's the what's the smallest
change i can make to the existing system
to move closer towards implementing this
particular behavior that the customer
has asked for
right test of that tv is all
an agile it's all about small steps i
make a small change
and it goes wrong i haven't got much to
throw away right
make a big change then i'm very
uninclined to throw it away when it goes
wrong
and i spent ages trying to hack it
around it right i recently
um you know i had that experience
basically on
my on broadcast project i realized that
um rather than trying to make something
uh
work it was just easier basically
effectively to rewrite it
because whatever decisions i've made in
the past were lost to me and
it was quicker to go in and rewrite the
whole thing right and i had tests that
helped me do that
and that resolved that issue in the same
way moving in small steps
i should take advantage of that idea
that basically maybe
that stuff doesn't work throughout a way
try rewriting
and it's important to understand that
it's we're focused on use cases and user
stories right user storage
user stories are just light lightweight
use cases right
and it's that which effectively drives
our tdt we have a user story which we're
given
the customer basically says i want this
thing to happen
and if we work with the customer we have
a set of acceptance criteria that give
us essentially rules
we can say hey when this happens that
happens right these
these are some numbers we can crunch to
prove that and is that
that's that's what we said we should say
about tdd hey what's the user story
what's this what's the hey what's the
demonstrator that's what i'm testing
right
what's the smallest thing i can do to
get towards that so if you go and look
at for example ron jeffrey's
um work where effectively his catas and
stuff where he's building for example
the bowling game
you go and look at what he's doing right
what he's doing is taking behaviors
about scoring a bowling game and each
time around he's saying what's the
smallest thing i can do
to move towards basically that set of
behaviors so i've got a
um on my github a copy basically
effectively
of uh kind of his rules and he just
you've got a set of acceptance criteria
that basically say what how do i want to
see
a bowling game work right and you can
just work your way through that
um so if tdd is capturing these
requirements this is my big objection to
bdd
tdd is dealing with these use cases and
user stories
you might ask the question well hang on
a minute isn't that what acceptance test
do you
we'll come back to that
um and the thing we mentioned earlier
right in the refactoring step
right i don't have to introduce new
tests if i break out new classes or new
methods
they are placed under test
by the original test that you have your
test gives you coverage
essentially of that behave of what what
that change you just made
when you refactor that challenge you
just made and refactoring is usually
safe steps which don't introduce new
paths etcetera
and effectively even if i say oh i'm
going to create some new methods or you
know what i want a little helper class
to deal with that i don't need new tests
the tests are on the behavior not on x
not on each individual class
if i need eight classes to implement
that that's great
i only necessarily need one test the
test probably
should be focused on what is exported
from the module there's other things in
a language that supports that should be
implementation digits which are hidden
and i supported from the module so i'm
thinking internals in c
sharp or you know single underscore and
python and a module right
things that effectively you don't expose
but those things don't need individual
tests and in refactoring
you often find that you're building that
class hierarchy
all you've got effectively under test is
the facade and that's great because it
means somebody else can come in
throw away your implementation rebuild
it
actually and provide the testing pass
know that their rework
has been a good solution to the problem
remember that refractoring is changing
the implementation without changing the
behavior if you're doing anything else
you're not doing with factoring
right um okay mention that
multiplication exported
um uh yeah could be a new class as well
right
um and so remember that you need to
follow this step red green refactor
green get your goal is to effectively
define the algorithm as far as possible
not to write clean code clean code in
the refactoring step
refraction is where you apply patterns
because you i understand
what the algorithm is to solve this
problem now now i know what the context
i have is
now i know if a pattern is an
appropriate choice right
so now i understand what complexity i
write a complex enough
solution to the problem and no more i
recommend usually going and reading a
book called
99 bottles of beer by sandy metz uh
it's a great exploration i don't
necessarily quite agree with some of the
steps about td it's a great exploration
of this idea of
using tests to avoid um increasing the
complexity of your code
all right customers write acceptance
tests
um uh there's another fallacy
unfortunately um
we don't really want to do that okay so
uh where did this idea come from so the
idea originally came
from the site this principle that we had
an on-site customer nowadays with an xp
and nowadays we think about that as
being say for example the product owner
and the product owner the idea was would
essentially help us
with defining the requirements um
looking deceptive criteria and testing
basically
the code right and so one of the uh
the kind of real stretch goal was
basically was well
why can't the customer actually write to
test right
and then the obstacle was being well
they can't write the test because
they're not a developer well what if we
created tools to let them write it in
their own language
or just fill in a table in an html table
they could write the tests so the the
idea behind acceptance testing was
originally customers would come in
and write the tests for us and that's
why
we have a dsl like cucumber or basically
we have a wiki page
or an html table and something like fit
so that the customers can write the test
directly
but how many of you actually have
customers writing those
did you use spec flow or cucumber
because
your customer sits with your team and
writes the tests
if you didn't why are you doing that
why not just you write your tests in an
x unit tool
what advantage have you gained by
putting it into basically another format
which you then have to write some
translation from and regex parsing and
fiddle
all that around in order to then run
your action an excellent tool
effectively
probably zero and i've never really seen
this work
i've never even seen customers review
them
all they earn is an additional burden on
the team because they're complicated and
hard to maintain
right my other question would be if i'm
doing unit testing
properly i'm doing tdd rather properly
right
i'm doing tdd i've already got tests for
my behaviors that express the acceptance
criteria described by the customer
that's what my tdd's got what are these
acceptance guys are keeping me
there's no difference
so james shaw is the person that wrote
one of people who helped write fit or
achieve the word coming
so james has skin in the game right he's
basically one of the people that helped
write it
also james's books on xp are great um if
you really want to understand how the xp
philosophy worked if you if you if you
missed out on that first time around
your experience scrum
go and read basically his art of agile
development
um uh his problems basically he he
pointed this out he said i've abandoned
using fit the tool that i wrote i've
abandoned using it because it doesn't
work
right and it's because because
effectively
customers don't do it and if customers
don't do it
don't do it that tool only exists for
customer consultation for the product
term if your product teller's not
writing the tests in your cucumber suite
don't do it
because they're more expensive they
create a maintenance burden they spend
much of their life
read because generally the the pattern
of process you use
says um i write them at the beginning
they're read until i get all the
implementation or the all the
implementation written and that means
you have whole suites they're supposed
to be read for a period of time
right that's really antithetical to the
way that ttd works where effectively
elsewhere should be green most of the
time
and it tends to be people ignoring those
tests because they're rare because
there's things in there that haven't
been built yet
and then you get this crunch at the end
of the iteration where everyone goes hey
we've got to fix the acceptance tests
right
and i think atd and i think bdd bears
basically a certain amount of
responsibility for this unfortunately
has really um broken
uh uh under our understanding of tdd
because the need in order to justify atd
basically because we already have tested
the acceptance criteria
for the behavior expressed by the
customer that's tdd
wanted to justify http we have to
effectively
um degrade tdd adjust testing units
so we've added all this unnecessary
complexity right
all these unnecessary tools that
basically effectively
are required to do dsls which the
developer is writing themselves not the
customer
to express the behavior which tdd should
have been expressing an x unit tool
which would have given us fast binary
feedback
so really if you're using these today
just ditch them
okay and again this is the point from
ken
originally this is a camera it's
originally in ttd by example
talking about http which i think people
are raising then and saying just don't
do it
right because you stare at a red bar for
too long
because these tests essentially must be
read until the implementation is done
let's rely on unit tests
right uh customer specified acceptance
criteria is what we really want instead
right so this is the way that james just
working um
uh sometimes called example uh driven
development but it's really just tdd
um but if you want another name for this
kind of tdd you could call example
driven development
but customers illustrate examples and
the developers basically use the
examples as a guide to write their tests
we see in the elaboration
customer says this is the user story
here the acceptance criteria
um and we only use those to write our
unique tests by taking
tests even i say unit tests it's just
because i'm saying right but developer
tests
okay and that's where we get something
to go from
okay it doesn't matter if you test first
or you test last that's another fallacy
that seems to come up people say well
um it doesn't matter i still get the
same test coverage right
and people say i i've seen people
actually literally say i like to explore
my code so what i do is i write
something at the very top level at the
outside contract
and then i go in in small bits filling
in individual details stubbing stuff out
until i get to the end and then right
then i write the test to express that
and you kind of like
uh okay that's tdd right
so the problem is uh you say i want to
execute unit test
after development tests right
and that's classical testing right
classical testing is
testing at the end of the line where
essentially you say once i've written
something
i'll then write tests it's a regression
proofing
so your modeling has to occur
when in advance of you getting tests
right
so the feedback comes after your model
has been
just created by you perhaps with crc
colors and white boards
um but also by the process of
implementation at the end
when you're complete you see if that
model is any good
then what happens if the model is no
good right
generally speaking people are very
reluctant to go back
and throw away all that code that
they've just written realizing the tests
have now told them at the end
that their model was rubbish okay
what they tend to do is then hack their
models make it work and so if you are
doing test after you are essentially
saying
i prefer waterfall-style development
that's what you're saying
i prefer design up front um and then
test at the end
classic phased waterfall development
that's that's your approach
and that's okay if that's what you
really want to do but please wear that
shirt proudly
that's what you have signed up to right
test last is
no there's no relation test traffic
um
one of the key issues here is this long
feedback loop
right the idea behind tdd is we move
quality left move quality up the line
right give you feedback on design
decisions
as you make them and you can do that by
red green refactor
you can't do that like a test after and
unfortunately
unit testing uh unit and integration
testing and all that
standing ins along with mock objects
implicitly push you
into test after even if you write test
at the same time you've really done the
design already
and effectively you are then just trying
to basically um write a test to
encapsulate that design
um one of the problems here is that
you're engaging in speculation
right you're writing speculative code
how do you know when you're done
right surely done basically is i've met
the requirements given to me by the
customer
but quite often in this model people go
away and write a whole lot of code
and then they add the test at the end
which can find the behavior the customer
wanted
and it may turn out that half the code
was completely unnecessary
right you slowed yourself down
considerably because you deliver stuff
the customer didn't need
and you may say oh the customer will
need that i know i'm smart the customer
always wants that
but how do you know until you actually
see what the customer wants whether your
implementation is right
and your tendency will be to say oh yeah
it's not quite what i built i can hack
what i built to make that work
right if you'd waited and found out what
the actual requirement was when it came
if it came you wrote better code
so the the thing we need to understand
is that we should basically
only write production code in response
to a test that's one of the key
principles of tdd
okay
we only write a test in response to a
requirement
so we can't write speculative code
there's a path from requirement to test
the thing that i
implemented
if i come to write my tests and
because and i don't i don't know what
the acceptance criteria are i don't know
what the behavior is
and and i feel like i'm stalled
well actually that's a prompt right it's
a prompt to say we don't understand this
story well enough let's get the product
on or the customer back into the room
let's talk to them
let's find out what we should actually
be building
all right
um as ken's kind of key point here is
tdd gives us two things it gives us
design contract first design
and it gives us scope control right we
don't write a necessary code
and that's what we test first
all right 100 test coverage your code
hopefully you'll begin to see that this
one probably
probably won't um uh work now even tdd
basically um ken at some point says cd4
religiously should result 100
coverage of code but that's because if
we do tdd right
right if we're writing programmer tests
we're basically following behaviors et
cetera
um and we are writing a test first we're
never writing any code
that wasn't prompted by a test so we
can't write
tests that basically doesn't have 100
coverage because why would we have
written code that didn't have a test
over it
we'd only get discrepancies if what we
were doing was essentially test first
and we'll test first by by the process
of introducing unit tests
because unit tests always are a test
after strategy
and so as soon as you try and do unit
tests you will effectively end up like
doing
tests after even if you are
simultaneously writing
or untested branches and refractions
without refracting stuff goes wrong
we may well find that essentially we
introduce a branch we get carried away
and that is the point effectively of co
coverage tools which basically say at
the beginning of the refactoring
i have this much coverage at the end of
the refactoring i should have the same
amount of coverage
i shouldn't basically have introduced me
positive to the code if i have it should
highlight to me hey you use this new
path
and nothing in the test expresses that
if you take that path out and then you
write the test that basically expresses
that particular behavior
if you can confirm that is genuine
requirement
of course we do actually have less than
right quite often so so why is that
is that because we've got problems right
is that because essentially um
things happen in the past that are wrong
one of the things that uh we need to
understand at this point is
not all of our code should be driven by
test driven development tdd is suitable
e4 expressing our funding our domain
finding basically the behaviors of that
domain and how it works
it's not super full of other things it's
not test first development not the
process we're describing here right
these processes to find fast binary
feedback right
what we don't want to do therefore is
drive tests about things that are
fragile or slow
or potentially um where effectively
exploratory testing would give us better
with better better feedback
we don't drive spikes rather throw away
code
spike is basically how we find stuff out
you don't know point writing tests
around it
it the feedback is the spike right
you don't have integration right if you
basically need essentially to figure out
whether your configuration is for your
your data for your database mapping is
correct that's not a tdd process
you're not exploring a behavior right
run some code and see if it works
that's the way you get feedback and if
you're worried about it changing sure
write a test and maybe use an excellent
tool after the protection against
regression
but that's not our tdd objective right
gd is about getting
a feedback on the behaviors that you're
encoding into the system it's not about
confirming that you can
follow the instructions on how to use
your rm correctly
don't if it tests out things that are
fragile will continue to break
like things that it's just over
networking connections right
don't do tds around things that are slow
so that you don't get fast binary
feedback and everyone doesn't run the
tests all the time
because it takes 20 minutes to run the
test suite
just use a test after approach to make
sure they're regression tested if you
need to
and often the fastest feedback is
something to run them not to write tests
at all
the goal of tdd is fast feedback on
design decisions that's what it's there
for
right if you can get faster feedback by
a different mechanism
use that instead
okay don't go third party code it's not
yours either right
um yeah so if not when your code is tdd
your entire code base won't have 100
coverage don't worry about that
focus your tdd efforts on the things
that make sense for tdd which is really
around
your domain model and that leads to kind
of the testing pyramid which kind of
says
um you know tdd's part of strategy
because tdd basically is a cheap way
of getting very fast feedback then we
should focus basically on making sure
that our
use cases the behavioral requirements of
the system are driven by tdd
as we move up the stack we may want to
use other techniques right
where effectively it's i o we may want
to automate and check regression but we
want to test that after
right we want to think monitoring
alerting is part of our
quality strategy right it tells us about
the behavior system gives us feedback
about things that
you might not be able to explore easily
otherwise distributed systems fell in
all sorts of interesting ways that tdd
is never going to discover for you
right um and it spoke to your testing
which basically asked the question which
is the opposite
is asking the question you know how do i
build this requirement things that i
want
this box testing is your qa saying let
me break this thing
right by using it in new and unexpected
ways
and all these things are valuable but
the higher the louder they are
the more expensive they are the slower
they are
and effectively therefore the longer the
time to feedback and the more cost to
get feedback
so get the cheap feedback if you can at
tdd
and then go up the ladder as you need to
all right so clean architecture is one i
always recommend as being a real help to
doing tdd
okay this is a classic clean
architecture model the clean
architecture is just the generic name
that's been created around hexagonal
onion
bce there are a whole set of patterns
that really just are the same thing
um and then really the key
characteristic basically
is that you have essentially a series of
layers
in the center you have your entities
which essentially is your domain model
if you like um around that you have a
domain service layer which essentially
is expressing
um uh the use cases right
we think of them as ports in hexagon
architecture i quite often think of them
as commands right
things that basically say um here is a
requirement
which may involve a number of entities
um so it's the behavior
right around that we have where you
integrate with frameworks and
other things that you need says right
wait write your controller but so that
your web framework can call you and pass
you
the http request as parameters it's
where you talk to your messaging
platform it's
where you talk to your database right
and beyond that is actually the
frameworks and the drivers that your
system needs and the key idea in all
clean architectures it depends inwards
right so things on the outer layer can
call things on the inner layer but not
in reverse
which tends to be why we need basically
interfaces
because if my use case
wants to basically write to a database
um
then what it needs to do basically is
have an interface that gets realized by
a concrete
database application by the outer layer
right that's all those are about that's
all
really injection that basically
interfaces should be about it's about
layering
right okay
so given that we can look something like
that
this right delivery mechanism boundary
interactor entity
boundary basically effectively things
like controllers interact effectively is
our use cases
entity is the things we're dealing with
we may have like an entity gateway that
means go and get stuff from storage
right when we have a request model
response model because our entities
effectively can't
leave can't go up beyond our interactor
so essentially our boundary effectively
has to deal with something else instead
that the interactive music
right you can't it's a rule from
jakobson but you basically your boundary
shouldn't talk directly to your entity
you should always go through the
interactive layer in between there's no
bypass
um and you're really should be passing
your entity back up therefore
be directly exposed that's where you get
dtos right class models and response
models
okay given we know that it seems clear
that basically we should
write most the majority of our tests
against the use case line
because tests exercise use cases
or user stories
that's what i write most of my tdd if i
have an interactor like a command
or i've got a dispatch model so i've got
a command and a handler
that's where i write most of my tests
our x unit suite is just another adapter
it's another thing driving it
right and we can also essentially see
that maybe it makes sense at this point
both from the depends
inward stage of this architecture and
from the symmetry of where we sit
to say that some of these things on the
outside the lio things that are fragile
and slow look like the good candidates
for things we should
mark right
sometimes the use case is too
coarse-grained
and i need to be a bit more fine-grained
and i can switch down to enters
kent calls this notion gears it's a it's
it's one of the craziest explain things
and i didn't realize america so many
americans understood how stick shifts
work
but the idea effectively is i choose a
suitable gear so high gear most of the
time
low gear when things get tricky so you
can shift down to entities and things
get tricky
this is what it looks like i've got an x
unit framework driving a test
the test has a request model and
response model right so
you can tell that you're dealing with
the api for software implementation
details because generally exposes
primitives not to main objects
right because your apis are much better
exposing
primitive structures not and things that
are defined at its level
not the things inside so interact and
then the entities before and then
essentially you can have a delivery
mechanism which has some kind of
in-memory db
for faking out purposes for a test okay
so your test is just driving the same
code
that other things drive
don't td other adapters generally
they're provided to you by framework
they should have tests that are running
basically the proof that they work and
don't tds your controller effective
etcetera and use that as your starting
point
it's dealing with issues like http it
should be skinny just hand over work to
your use case
right it's another adapter like x unit
if you need confirmation of stuff you
may want to have some kind of scripted
tests that trace end to end let's show
you the whole thing hangs together
and that essentially you haven't you
know fluffed up when you basically been
doing your routine table in your
controller or assigning your orm
uh mappings that you need right you only
need a few of those just to test the
happy path
trace the whole thing hangs together for
you and that's really about those
configuration concerns which is really
what they are um
all right let's basically summarize um
the fallacies developers write unit
tests trigger frame you test is a new
function
customers write acceptance tests doesn't
matter if you test first or last and you
want 100 test coverage of your account
right principles you should be following
if you're writing developer or
programmer tests
right the trigger trick for you to write
a test should be a new behavior
um the customer should be writing
acceptance criteria
um you should only write production code
in response to a test
but not all of your code should be
driven by tdd
all right and we're done thanks very
much
um i can i will hang out for questions
uh
at the but i know it's a break so um
people are probably recording but they
will hang out people want to chat